all right we'll start with 187 and go to
133 after them oh my goodness hi 187s
over here ariana debose baz bammy bazz
hi honey hi to you too congratulations
thank you you know
after winning this oscar started a long
time ago it did because i saw you on
broadway 12 years ago working your
what's it off tell me how you got from
there to here oh
please
i think
i don't know if there's an easy way to
put that or answer that question i can
tell you
a lot of hard work a lot of
determination a lot of
active choice to take my rejections as
redirections
um
i was just saying you know when i was in
the ensemble of hamilton mind you
as an ensemble member i had a role that
barely spoke all i did was dance but i
chose at some point to
try for more and to be frank it wasn't
met with you know thunderous applause um
some some folks kind of looked at me
like i was crazy and i had to choose to
believe that i was deserving of more and
go and train to be better
and honestly just choosing
choosing myself and choosing to believe
that i was worthy and
and the willingness to humble myself and
do the work that's how that's how this
happened this is magic but it's magic
that
um did not come without effort
yeah thanks paz
all right 133 and then followed by 116.
hi over here hi queen hello ahees with
buzzfeed um i just again want to say
congratulations i loved you in west side
story thank you and this is also such an
important
award
twofold because this is your first big
major role in a feature film and
nomination and win and you won the award
that rita moreno won as the first
puerto rican woman and latino person
to win the academy award for supporting
actress in the same role so i just kind
of wanted to ask you about this kind of
full circle moment and you know your
reaction to it and like you know if you
talked with rita earlier tonight about
your win and like you know compared
oscars or
[Laughter]
no you know it is it is uh i don't i
don't know if i see it as a
it's a historical moment
it's a layer on a layer on a layer and i
think um
this is the first time that a female
role has been honored twice but i think
it's really important to note that our
anitas while they share a name they are
different women
you know her anita is iconic and
legendary and will always be and now
mine has been
shown light upon in this way and i'm
very proud of that because i set out to
create a woman
that stood on her own two feet
and while
there are 60 years of legacy between our
anitas mayanita is not dependent on it
she celebrates what was and what is what
can be how we move forward
so it is historical and it is
gosh i don't know it's it's overwhelming
because i could see rita tonight it was
really special to be able to see her
sort of willing me to to say what i
wanted to say
and um
i think
the other layers i'm an openly
queer woman of color
and not for nothing
that's freaking awesome you guys
um
so i'm
the second latina to win an acting award
i'm afro-latina
i'm an openly queer woman of color and
i think that just proves that there's
space there's space for us and it's a
beautiful moment to be seen
and i'm really honored by that
i hope that answers your question
now i apologize you all have great
questions but we have to cut her short
i'm sorry i'm so sorry we're gonna take
one more question from our virtual press
room from variety okay there will be a
slight delay
hi uh
uh i buzzfeed actually i think took my
question a little bit because i wanted
to ask if you had a chance to talk at
all with rita
since your win
no
i hadn't i have not spoken to her yet
i'm really hoping i can catch her at the
governor's ball but we did have a
beautiful moment on the carpet i'm
really hoping someone got a photo of it
um and she just said are you ready
you're in for the ride of your life and
i'm rooting for you
and i think that's
i don't know that type of support it's
i don't know it's everything but
generationally between actresses you
know the industry has changed so much
and quite frankly her existence has
opened many doors not just for me but
for many women in this industry many
latinas and i'm personally just i don't
know it makes me really happy to be able
to stand beside her because she's not
alone anymore people don't talk about
that when you're the first of something
it's lonely
it's lonely
i mean at least that's what i've learned
sometimes so it's really
i don't know it's a privilege and it's
an honor to be the person that gets to
stand beside her and guess what we're
ready and waiting for
more folks so because there's space
let's go
[Music]